hello freak so I'm not sure if
this is where you want to go but as you
as you are describing this sort of quest
for improvement one of the one of the
threats of that reflux or one of the
dangers of that reflux is precisely how
totalitarian ideologies develop where
they argue that our current state of the
world is faulty and if only you
implement our ideology the jewel it
could be communism it could be is right
it could be perfect if then it could be
perfect socialism exactly so so there is
a way by which we could reach that
utopia if only you adhere to our
ideology so there's a real danger in
sort of succumbing to that and I by the
way that's one of the I'm reading right
now a book by William Gardner who might
come on my show he's a I think a
political scientist his book is called
the Great Divide where he actually lays
out some of the sort of fundamental
foundational differences between
liberals and conservatives in terms of
their worldviews and how because of
these starting positions being so
different having no overlap between them
the Venn diagrams don't overlap that's
why you end up speaking over each other
without being able to find common ground
so one of these differences is that and
and I described something similar using
different terms
a lot of the quote liberals and
progressives view our brain as being
blank slates right it's infinitely
malleable right and so if you see
differences between people it can't be
because there was a starting point
difference Michael Jordan was not
innately likely to be better than you in
basketball there were some environmental
conditions that led Michael Jordan to
become who he is and not got sad to be
the best NBA player ever and if only we
can find the appropriate social
intervention strategies then we could
all have equality of outcomes and so
that is a faulty understanding of human
nature because human nature as you of
course you know is really an interaction
of our biology and our environment but
so much of the welfare state is based on
this idea that no we need more
of your tax money so that we could
implement a social engineering program
so that we could reach that utopia where
we are all equal outcome and frankly I
think that that's complete nonsense it
is fascinating that people seek comfort
in communism and socialism for that very
reason like they almost are trying to
slow down the competition that they
can't win right exactly
yeah I see it by the way it by
University so in Canada is a very sort
of social welfare state and Quebec the
province where I live is sort of
socialist on wealth on steroids and so
in the context of the universities of
all of the metrics of reward are removed
so that we can have equality of outcomes
and the way that you instantiate that is
through the union's
right so there's a very powerful union
that ensures that all professors are
roughly treated equally because we're
all social ads there's a queen bee and
then the rest of us are all equal but of
course humans are not equal some are
smarter some work harder some are more
apathetic some are honest some are
cheaters and so this idea of constantly
having to have some external agent
manage the process so that we could all
be equal to me is grotesque and it goes
back to I think probably our first
conversation you and I had when I was
saying that you know I would love to
eventually come to Southern California
because at least in the United States
the society has been less parasitized by
the social welfare idea of course the
Democrats are more so than the
Republicans but as a general rule Canada
is basically pure social welfare we're
all equal and of course Justin Trudeau
certainly trying to push that idea even
more he's too handsome that's that guy's
problem
he's trying to make up for the fact that
it's beautiful and he's trying to be
super sweet to everybody that's what's
going on up there
you